well every single House Democrat except
one is backing a bill that would require
all high schools nationwide to let
biological men compete on women's sports
teams now to most people that seems
insane and to female athletes it is of
course grossly unfair but now it's
orthodoxy science and common sense are
irrelevant through orthodoxy will not be
questioned meanwhile a taxpayer-funded
study sponsored by the NIH National
Institutes of Health is allowing sex
change hormones to be given to children
as young as eight years old so what are
the effects of that do we know dr. mark
Siegel is a Fox News medical contributor
he joins us tonight doctor thank you
very much for coming on so whenever you
have an advancement in culture that
nobody's allowed to question and then it
bleeds over into science it makes me
nervous no matter what it is whether I
like it or not I haven't heard a single
person ask the obvious question what is
the effect of giving hormone suppressing
drugs voluntarily to children I think
there's a long term effect first of all
puberty blockers which you start with
like an anti estrogen or an
anti-androgen that followed by hormone
therapy as they enter adolescence can
lead to neurological problems problems
with bone growth and sterility later on
so that's just the physical issues
there's also the psychological impact
and the neurological impact of having
transitioned someone that made the site
later on that they want to go back the
other way of course we should support
transgender children of course we should
support a child's choice and that's what
the American Academy of Pediatrics says
but when they talk about giving these
drugs these hormones I get very nervous
and I think to myself who's super
imposing their will here is it doctors
or is it parents because again a child
is someone that I want to watch develop
there's no reason to be questioning
sexuality and sexual choice in a
nine-year-old we have to wait and see
which way it goes yeah I mean it almost
sounds like Munchausen's by proxy I mean
it sounds like the parents sort of
displacing onto the kid may be something
that's going on with them or who knows
but it doesn't seem responsible at all
and it seems incredibly risky it seems
demented to be honest with you where the
adults standing up and
we'll wait a second you know 100 adults
wrote a letter saying we don't agree
with the American Academy of Pediatrics
and by the way your point about
Munchausen by proxy I think is excellent
cuz I think parents have guilt they
think wait a minute maybe I'm not doing
enough maybe we really aren't going this
is our culture now right we have to
listen to every word but I think our job
as parents is to guide to support not to
be mean or anything but to support and
watch development in progress I don't
think we give drugs and I don't think we
look for doctors that do our bidding for
us so term effect here if you were to
stand up at a medical conference and say
what you just did which strikes me as
extremely moderate you you know way more
I mean right it doesn't seem
controversial what you just said how
would you be received depends on the
conference you know I have a feeling
that the Democratic lawmakers are trying
to pander to a certain group but it
depends doctors are varied on this issue
and I think a lot of doctors would agree
with me do no harm we're not dealing
with the disease we're dealing with a
developing child let them develop
support their psychological development
and by the way the earlier point when
we're talking about athletics I do now I
believe it's a competitive advantage to
allow someone that is born a male and
then and had all these years of
testosterone building up muscle right
building up bone and then we allow them
to compete with women that's giving them
a competitive advantage I call that
juicing well of course it is I mean
that's called biology but it's being
denied by the United States House of
Representatives explicitly and by the
interest group that is pushing this and
that's shocking to me anyway doctor
thanks very much for clarity on that
sucker